I believe in dreams dreams you can live
in if you design the space where the
story will happen
[Music]
nothing ugly can get in I have three
friends who have met their husbands and
I'm Debra I'm John oh my God look at you
you're inspiring chairs upstairs I'm
trying to find somebody who's a good
person he's so good to me he gives me so
much huh
there's something wrong with him do you
not see that Ronnie thinks that John is
creepy do you really believe that he
doesn't want your money
hey it wasn't the safe kiddo does he
tell you where he's going I don't know
do some snooping I hired a private
detective threats harassment
intimidation is it possible that's not
him we need to figure out why he's lying
to you I want something I know how to
buckle down it's been in prison prison
for not being a woman doing drugs they
are not me they all say they are you
you know is she ready for what might
happen what do you mean what might
happen
I don't think I never saw who he really
was
whatever happens between us remember I
love you
you